if you're at all aware of how funny and
Unapologetic Carrie Fisher was in real
life you probably wouldn't be surprised
by her hilarious comments on the costume
she had to wear in Return of the Jedi
Princess Leia's much talked about Return
of the Jedi bikini has raised eyebrows
since it first appeared on movie screens
in 1983 in the third Star Wars film
Carrie Fisher who will forever be known
for the role was reluctantly clad in the
abbreviated attire when her character
was being held captive by the Monstrous
bulbous space gangster Jabba the Hutt
since then some have dubbed the tiny
togs the slave layer bikini what do you
think Ralph how do you like it where's
the other half of that costume
some claim it steals the show from
Harrison Ford as Han Solo and Mark
Hamill as Luke Skywalker as their
characters struggle to rescue Leia as
Carrie Fisher herself expressed in years
of interviews it wasn't exactly a day at
the beach nevertheless Carrie Fisher was
always ready with her writing talent and
sense of humor years before she became
one of the top Hollywood script doctors
punching up numerous movie scripts she
was on the set of Return of the Jedi
when she decided that Princess Leia had
something more to add to a scene Fischer
came up with a few lines to say right on
the spot 33 years later before the
premiere of Star Wars episode 8 The Last
Jedi she recalled this moment for
National Public Radio when we first
rehearsed it harrisoned and Mark are
brought in front of Jabba they talk to
jabba jabba talks to Harrison and Mark
and then they're let off they never say
hey how are you so as they were being
led off I said in the rehearsal don't
worry about me I'll be fine seriously
which I thought they should have kept
him there in addition to not having her
clever line used in the film Carrie
Fisher also had to deal with the Highly
Questionable public display of wearing a
revealing costume in the movie she was
forced to wear the costume by Jabba the
Hutt you tell that slimy piece of
worm-ridden Filth he'll get no such
pleasure from us right in real life the
costume was provided for Fisher by
Return of the Jedi co-writer and Star
Wars Creator George Lucas who approved
the design according to one of the
designers they did respond to a request
for some modifications to allow more
comfort in the action scenes she
explained the situation to NPR it was
like where am I in all of this I have to
stay with the slug with the big tongue
Nearly Naked which is not a style choice
for me it wasn't my choice when George
Lucas showed me the outfit I thought he
was kidding and it made me very nervous
I had to sit very straight because I
couldn't have lines on my sides like
little creases no creases were allowed
so I had to say it very very rigid
straight but tell me why I can't no no
there is no way however Fisher admitted
that there was a silver lining to the
scene in retrospect she used the
experience to enhance her performance as
she explained what redeems it is I get
to kill him which was so enjoyable I
sawed his neck off with that chain that
I killed him with I really relished that
because I hated wearing that outfit and
sitting there rigid straight and I
couldn't wait to kill him Princess
Leia's golden bikini may have been brief
but there was no telling how long
Fisher's love-hate relationship with the
costume would go on this time to the
higher part of me they hire like 80
percent of me and they say get rid of
that extra 20. Fisher fielded a parade
of awkward conversations regarding the
golden bikini for the rest of her days
through it all she proved that a sense
of humor could be as powerful as a
lightsaber after witnessing the cosplay
worlds of Comic-Con and other events
Fisher remarked about her fondness for
seeing male cosplayers turn the other
cheeks on the infamous miss outfit she
was at her acerbic vest when she told
NPR my favorite costume to see is the
metal bikini on men that is what has
been happening a lot a lot and not thin
men by the way so that makes me feel
good about myself kind of a before and
after stick this is way after not only
is Princess Leia fatter she's a guy
Carrie Fisher's NPR interview would be
among her last she would pass away one
month later however as Luke Skywalker
said
no one's ever really gone
accordingly fans will never truly be
without the wit wisdom and talent of
Carrie Fisher it's almost always a few
clicks away